i love what you're wearing i love again
you have done such a cool thing
you are known for bringing uh very
classy cool pantsuit sort of looks
back into the public eye and i commend
you because you look amazing thank you
thank you very much just keeping up with
tradition yeah it's do you have a
what's your collection like is it
incredible at this point your collection
you know it's funny um i actually had a
friend call and ask me if she could
borrow
a suit the other day and i said i i
actually i don't have any
and she said what are you talking about
i was like i borrow all my clothes
really i don't i don't i don't actually
get to keep any of these suits
okay um but um so you're literally
borrowing stuff
like you'll you'll find out that you
have to zoom with conan o'brien
in 10 minutes and you're running out the
door asking neighbors can i borrow
a pant suit i have a very lovely stylist
who helps me out but but i don't
actually get to keep any of this you
know i basically model it and get
it back so it's all an illusion we uh we
found this photo of you
when you were a little kid and you're
still wearing a suit that's true
actually i mean yes i have i have been
rocking the suits for quite some time
yeah look at me look at my little look
at my little business haircut i have
no i love this it looks like you're
there to sue somebody
looks like you're a lawyer